في العام الماضي دخل الرئيس الفرنسي الى
ملفات الشرق الاوسط من بوابه العراق من
خلال قمه بغداد الاولى مانويل ماكرون الذي
زار العراق مرتين خلال ولايته الاولى يعود
اليوم للمشاركه في قمه بغداد الثانيه التي
تعقد على ساحل البحر الميت في الاردن
وتشارك فيها مصر والسعوديه والامارات وقطر
وتركيا وايران على ان يكون التمثيل على
مستوى وزراء الخارجيه فيما غابت سوريا
ولبنان عن الحضور وعن هدف القمه قالت
الرئاسه الفرنسيه
العراق نفسه بالكاد خرج من تصادمات عنيفه
بين الفرقاء السياسيين انتهت بتسويه هشه
وبتعيين محمد الشيعه السوداني رئيسا
للوزراء وسيكون هذا الاجتماع الدولي
اختبار للمسؤول العراقي الجديد الاقرب الى
ايران من سلفه مصطفى الكاظم
ايران التي لها يد متغلله في العديد من
بلدان المنطقه تعيش حاليا على واقع
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه وانهيار جهود احياء
الاتفاق النووي لذلك سيكون لانعاش
المفاوضات النوويه نصيب هاما من قمه بغداد
الثانيه التي يحضرها مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي والمنسق
الاوروبي لمباحه ومن المتوقع ان يتناول
لقاء بغداد قضايا مشتركه على غرار
الاحترار المناخي والامن الغذائي والتعاون
الاقليمي في مجال الطاقه كما سيكون
الايمان والمكرون لقاء مع ملك الاردن عبد
الله الثاني الذي تصفه باريس بالحليف في
محاربه الارهاب